there is a growing mystery surrounding
the disappearance of a Saudi journalist
who's been critical of Saudi Arabia's
powerful crown prince Washington Post
contributor Jamal Khashoggi vanished in
Turkey last week after entering the
Saudi consulate he'd been living in
self-imposed exile in the United States
the State Department says it is closely
following his disappearance in Istanbul
Holly Williams is outside the Saudi
consulate there Holly good morning good
morning this is a bizarre and disturbing
story Jamal has Shoji a respected Saudi
Arabian journalist visited the Saudi
consulate here in Istanbul Turkey last
Tuesday
apparently in order to get an official
document that he needed to marry his
Turkish fiancee but after entering the
building which you can see just behind
me he disappeared and his fiance and
friends say they haven't heard from him
since Turkish officials have told
journalists they believe her soldier was
murdered inside the consulate but so far
they've provided no evidence to back
that claim up Saudi Arabia denies that
it murdered or abducted her Shoji and
officials even allow journalists inside
the consulate in an attempt to prove
that he is not there now Jamal has
showed he had spoken out against the
Saudi government in its powerful Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman condemning a
lack of free speech in the
ultra-conservative Islamic state under
the Crown Prince Saudi Arabia has
launched a series of social reforms
including allowing women to drive but at
the same time the Saudi government has
become increasingly intolerant of any
form of dissent locking up critics and
rights campaigners Gayle Thank You Holly
Williams reporting from Istanbul